اشكر معالي السيد حسين ابراهيم طه على
كلمته وبذلك نختم الاستفتاحيه ونشكر اصحاب
الفخامه والمعالي الضيوف
والان اعلن عن بدء جلسه اعمال القمه وارجو
من الجميع التزام بالوقت المحدد ادعو
جلاله الملك عبد الله الثاني ابن الحسين
ملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه لالقاء كلمته
فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد نبيل
العربي الهاشمي الامين اخي صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود وصاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
السعود على استضافه هذه القمه وعلى حرص
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه على
تعبير التعاون العربي
كما اشكر الاشقاء في الجزائر على استضافه
القمه السابقه اخواني القاده الحضور
الكرام ان منظومه العمل العربي المشترك
بحاجه دوما الى التطوير والتجديد وهنا
ياتي دور جامعه الدول العربيه في العمل
على تعظيم التعاون وخاصه الاقتصادي بين
دولنا
لمواجهه تحديات الازمات الدوليه
واشير هنا الى اليه تعاون الثلاثي بين
الاردن والاشقاء في مصر والعراق
والشراكه الصناعيه التكامليه لتنميه
اقتصاديه مستدامه والتي تضم الاردن
والامارات ومصر والبحرين بالاضافه الى
مشاريع التعاون المستمره مع الاشقاء في
دول الخليج كامثله لما يمكن تحقيقه بشكل
اوسع اخواني القاده الحضور الكرام لا تزال
القضيه الفلسطينيه محور اهتمامنا ولا يمكن
ان نتخلى عن سعنا لتحقيق السلام العادل
والشامل الذي لن يتحقق اذا لم يحصل الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق على حقه في الدوله
الفلسطينيه المستقله ذات السياده على خطوط
الرابع من حزيران عام
1967 وحسبتها
الشرقيه على اساس حل الدولتين لا يمكن
للسلام والامن ان يتحقق مع استمرار بناء
المستوطنات
ومصادره الاراضي وهدم البيوت وتهجير
الفلسطينيه من اراضيهم وتدمير الفرص
المتبقيه لتحقيق حل الدولتين الذي يمنح
الشعب الفلسطيني حقوقه المشروع
فالبديل عن ذلك سيضع المنطقه باكملها على
طريق الصراع المستمر وليس هناك اهم بنسبه
لنا من احترام الوضع التاريخي والقانوني
القائم في المقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه
في القدس المدينه المقدسه التي نكرس كل
امكانياتنا من اجل حمايتها والحفاظ على
هويتها العربيه
الاسلاميه والمسيحيه انط من الوصايه
الهاشميه على هذه المقدسات اخواني القاده
الحضور الكرام لقد حضرنا مرارا من استمرار
ازمه سوريا دون حل فقد دفع الشعب السوري
الشقيق ثمنها غاليا وانعكست اثارها علينا
جميعا
ونرحب اليوم بعوده سوريا الى جامعه
العربيه
كخطوه مهمه نامل ان تسهم في جهود انهاء
الازمه ونؤكد هنا على اهميه تعزيز المسار
السياسي الذي انطلق من اجتماع عمان وبنى
على المبادره الاردنيه والجهود السعوديه
والعربيه
لانهاء الاسباب
ومعالجه التناسب ومعالجه تداعياتها
الانسانيه والامنيه
والسياسيه لكي يعود اللاجئون الى وطنهم
اخوان القادم لحضور الكرام ان استقرار
العراق استقرار لمطقتنا وانه جزء من امنه
القومي واننا في هذا الصدد ندعم الخطوات
التي تقوم بها الحكومه العراقيه بما يعيد
للعراق دوره ومكانته ضمن محيطه العربي
ويعزز استقاره واصدار الازدهاره وسيادته
على اراضيه
ونتطلع
للبناء على مؤتمر بغداد الاول ومؤتمر
بغداد الثاني في تعزيزي التعاون الاقليمي
مع العراق
الاخوه القاده الحضور الكرام لا مجال
للتباطؤ في انتهاز الفرص امامنا تحقيقا
لمصالح بلداننا وشعوبنا لذا فلابد من
تكثيف اللقاءات العربيه الدوريه وعلى اعلى
المستويات لتحقيق التكامل الاقتصادي في
منطقتنا وتوحيد جهودنا السياسيه والامنيه
وفي القتام اجدد شكر لاخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين وللحكومه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه ولشعبها العزيز على
استضافه هذه القمه داعيا الله عز وجل ان
يلهمنا النجاح والتوفيق لما فيه الخير
لاوطاننا وشعوبنا والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات